for you to basically chastise me about
uh what trump has done for the black
community and especially coming from joy
behar i thought i thought
you know you're number one not in
baltimore you don't live in one of these
dangerous cities
and you're not black and so i just
thought you know how could you
basically tell me how i should be
feeling in this situation
i'm on the ground every single day my
team is out there seven days a week
knocking doors
we register voters five days a week and
so i wanted to talk about all the great
grassroots things we were doing
as republicans you know when i talked
about this in my rnc convention speech
republicans usually write off the inner
cities and so i wanted to talk about the
fact that we're actually providing an
option for inner city communities and it
just kind of went left
all right everybody this is a reuben
report on the fly today
joining me is kim klasik she's a
republican candidate for congress in
maryland's seventh district which covers
baltimore
kim had quite a morning and i reached
out to her and she immediately responded
so here we are
kim how you doing hey how are you i'm
doing
doing well so far i'm doing pretty well
but you have had one of those mornings
because
you went viral and i've wanted to have
you on the show but you were on the view
this morning
and we're going to show the clip in just
a second but before we get to the clip
that everybody's talking about
did you kind of have a sense that it
might go in this direction i just want
to get your sense of like where your
head was at before and then we'll show
the clip
yeah so um the view actually the booker
called me
uh yesterday to basically give me a
rundown and talk to me about the
questions that uh the ladies were gonna
ask me
um so she gave me about 20 questions she
said we'll get to five of them but you
know just so you have them
uh you'll know exactly where we're going
um so you know i
honestly from the questions that she
gave me i thought it was going to be
kind of an even keel
conversation i thought they wanted to
know a little bit about
you know what i want to do in baltimore
the policies that i'll put forth
so i didn't see it coming to you know
what about trump what about trump uh but
when it did i just thought you know what
i'm here to talk about
what i want to bring to the table in
district seven so uh
you know i just said okay you know i've
had enough of this i'm just gonna keep
going and and just you know be honest
and be myself at this point yeah okay so
before we show the clip i should just
add
that before this happened in the clip
you had a really nice exchange with
megan mccain
totally respectful you got to talk about
your ideas
and then uh joy bae heart chimed in so
we'll throw to the clip come on kim
excuse me i have to say something to you
he told bob woodward
that it was a very serious issue and
it's airborne
and that it was terrible and then he
went out and told the american people
don't wear masks it's all going to go
away
you have to put some blame on your
president i'm sorry you're putting it on
something
extraneous here talk to the point please
is this is this joy speaking of joy
this year enjoy that yeah raided around
in black face not too long ago
come on joe i don't think you should be
asking questions i am excuse me
excuse me the black community had my
back
they know that that was not he had fun
that was an homage
oh please community community has your
back
the black community has your back yeah
the community did not
vote for you the black you
can i speak or
[Music]
okay so that is the clip that is going
round the world
right now were you ready with that like
were you ready just
to be like if they go that route i'm
gonna have to pull out the blackface
thing
no i honestly i wanted to just really
strictly stick to the policies and i
wanted to talk a little bit more about
my opponent you know i did lose in the
special election
uh my opponent has been sworn in since
may 5th and i wanted to basically
highlight the fact that he hasn't done
anything
since being in the seat um so when they
kept going on the trump situation i
thought you know what
for you to basically chastise me about
uh what trump has done for the black
community and especially coming from joy
behar i thought i thought
you know you're number one not in
baltimore you don't live in one of these
dangerous cities
and you're not black and so i just
thought you know how could you
basically tell me how i should be
feeling in this situation
i'm on the ground every single day my
team is out there seven days a week
knocking doors
we register voters five days a week and
so i wanted to talk about all the great
grassroots things we were doing
uh as republicans you know and i talked
about this in my rnc convention speech
republicans usually write off the inner
cities and so i wanted to talk about the
fact that we're actually providing an
option for inner city communities and it
just kind of went left
it went left no no pun intended um what
what do you make of the line that joy
said which is
i have the support of the black
community and that there was two things
it was i have the support of the black
community and that her black face was an
homage somehow because she's a lefty
when she does blackface
it's an homage but of course we know if
someone on the right did
blackface to be silly or halloween or
whatever it might be
we know this is not going to be taken as
an homage what do you make of those two
things
yeah i don't know how she could even
reconcile with those you know we saw
megan from fox news remember she had her
own daily talk show
and she was just taking kelly out yeah
she was just talking about the fact that
she didn't realize
that you know paying an homage for
blackface uh was disrespectful
remember she was talking about how kids
grew up you know doing the michael
jackson and
and that was their costume halloween so
she was actually reprimanded just for
talking about it
and so here's an individual that
actually did it and then she says to me
you know the black community has her
back
because you know i guess she's joy behar
i don't know i don't know her very well
um but what i will say is you know it
didn't make any sense to me it was very
unfair
and this is kind of what we see in the
media today you've got megyn kelly
who basically gets chastised and people
are trying to cancel her
for talking about her even asking the
question and then you've got joey bahar
on the other hand
who actually did it but she should be
you know able to do so because i guess
she's on the left and so
this is what i think we see a lot media
bias um but you know
i'm not standing for it what about that
phrase the black community because
there's something about that phrase if
you say the black community the gay
community whatever it is it's as
as if these people all think the same
thing and she
has the gall to say it to you you happen
to be black nobody cares but
if you're saying the black community
supports me well well i don't think kim
does
yeah absolutely i've been black for 38
years you know i come from a blackley
you know it's like i can't believe that
people say these kind of things and i
think this is something that even
candice owens has touched on before
you know you can't be a white liberal or
anybody you know of a different color
and tell us about our community i can't
tell a jewish person
how they should feel you know with the
anti-semitism that we see across the
country
you know so we have to make sure we
allow those people to still have a voice
at the same time i'm not the kind of
person to put everybody in a box i think
that's divisive
but again i was ready to talk about the
policies i was ready to talk about
career opportunities that i want to
bring to baltimore
um and i thought you know what this is a
great time to talk to the other side of
the aisle
i never get invited to cnn or msnbc or
you know left-wing media
they don't even want me on there so i
thought this is a great chance to just
reach that audience and talk about what
i want to bring to the community
as a member of congress and it kind of
just went
a completely different way i'm sorry
that it ended up that way but at the
same time
i'm not sorry for defending myself yeah
well i don't think you have anything to
be sorry for because you you were a
total pro but you know because we talk
about these things in the
in the context of identity politics that
they're kind of throwing on us
like the the female element of this like
if you were to ask the ladies
of the view i'm sure all of them would
say we're we're for all women
we're for all women and yet the way
sunny framed her first question to you
was
was deeply dismissive we just watched
what what joy did to you
what do you make about that sort of
thing the way republican or just
right-leaning women or just
non-progressive women are are treated by
these women yeah so there's a trend
right now it's called uh
hashtag win with black women right and
they're talking about the fact that they
were so excited that kamala harris was
picked
as joe biden's uh vp right that was the
whole thing but it's only win with black
women
if you are a democrat if you think like
them you know if you're a black woman
running as a republican
then it's like oh my gosh i can't
believe you're running you're a [ __ ]
you're uncle tom you're all these things
and so for me you know when you're in
the black community and you've been
voting for democrats for over 50 years
they do take our vote for granted and
that's what i was kind of showing in
baltimore
you know for us to move the needle we
have to have allies on both sides of the
aisle
so i don't understand why we do this we
chastise each other
uh because we want to run in a different
party i noticed in the white community
you can run as a democrat or republican
they don't actually you know chastise
you for it but in the black community we
have something totally different going
on
so it's it's to me you know they just
want you to think the same
i guess they always want you to do it
but i look at those women in the view
and i know they are both
are all of them are millionaires you
know they live in a different
basically society than the people do in
west baltimore i know sonny said she's
from baltimore i wanted to ask her
when's the last time she's been to west
baltimore
um because it is it's we got 17 000
vacant homes we have a poor education
system
um and we have crime and violence and so
for me it's like i don't think they
understand because they're not on the
ground
they don't feel it like we do here and
so that was my point and i hope uh
that point got across yeah so i want to
do a bigger interview with you before
the election so people can really talk
about your ideas but we just wanted to
do this quick
in light of the view thing but just
let's just do a couple things because i
think you made some really interesting
points also
in the interview despite everything uh
is it 52 years 53 years of democratic
rule in baltimore
yeah 53 years yep we've been underdone
53
do you sense when you say that to people
like the average person in baltimore
when you tell them that when they say
okay we got all these problems we got
crime we got drugs we got homelessness
blah blah blah when you say to them okay
i hear you i agree we got 53 years of
democratic rule
does that do you think that actually is
starting to get through to people
because we see this in all of the big
cities that have the problems they seem
to all be run by democrats for decades
it's just a fact
yeah absolutely i mean our polling is
going to come back next week i think on
tuesday but
we have a lot of people that have been
saying you know what i'm voting for kim
klasik
they get it they understand you know
voting for the same party having your
vote taken for granted
you know this is a situation i posted
last year of videos of the fact that
there are certain neighborhoods where
they can't even get the trash picked up
i mean this is a real serious situation
this is 2020
it's america and people shouldn't be
living like this so i don't know why the
women on the view would actually
you know be mad at me for trying to make
a black community better and give them a
better quality of life
but that's where we are today and that's
just how divisive things are and how
polarizing it is
in certain parts of the media yeah so
you gave a pretty spectacular speech i
think at the rnc
and can you just talk a little bit you
know i think still
it's sort of like the stereotype related
to 53 years of democratic rule people
can't understand
that maybe you want to change that can
you talk a little bit about what you've
seen
in the last year or two going on with
the republican party because it does
seem to me that it's getting a lot wider
we're now i just saw a poll
something like 45 percent of gay men are
gonna are going to vote republican like
these are crazy numbers and we're seeing
similar things with with the black
community something like 30 percent now
can you talk about that a little bit
absolutely so i think there's going to
be a lot
of people especially in the black
community voting for president trump
you have to think first and foremost a
lot of people don't even want to admit
it because you know the canceled culture
and the backlash from it
but people understand i mean when you
have president trump tweeting out
look district seven if you vote for
kimberly klasik she wants to bring
career opportunities she wants to bring
businesses
people understand that's basically him
saying if she's elected and i'm
re-elected
we are going to make baltimore great
again you know we were once a
manufacturing powerhouse here
and we allowed all those jobs to go
overseas during the clinton
administration
and i think trump you know he's all
about the economy and he wants to bring
a lot of those jobs back i want to bring
that biotech industry here
to baltimore and we can do that um but
at the same time it's like look if
you're not here on the ground
and you don't understand firsthand what
people are going through
um then i i really don't understand how
you can comment on it
you know i know sonny said she grew up
in baltimore i have not seen her in west
baltimore a day in my life and i've been
in this area for 10 years now
but at the same time it's like look why
don't we come up with solutions
why are we going back and forth
basically saying who's black enough or
who's not black enough
that's just a distraction we gotta make
some real results come to the area
okay so speaking of baltimore there
there was another moment in the clip
today where when sunny asks her first
question but you know she doesn't really
say hello she basically kind of throws
you under us oh you're not living in
baltimore right now she's from baltimore
uh and you had a great response to her i
thought
uh could could you just kind of repeat
well what what you've done in baltimore
and why you care about baltimore
yeah so for the past eight years i've
been working with my non-profits
workforce development
we haven't gotten any grants received
any money you know it's kind of
something that we did on our own but we
helped over 200 women
become gainfully employed 30 went on to
be financially independent
and so for me that's what i'm trying to
do as a member of congress is bring
those career opportunities
uh focus more on job training putting
apprenticeship programs to the high
schools like this is all stuff that i
wanted to talk about on the view
but i wasn't given that opportunity but
you know that's what it's about
getting people back to work you know
getting some of that crime and violence
down
because there are opportunities and so
for me i feel like you know sonny if
she's from baltimore
and she sees how bad we're suffering
here why hasn't she tried to come home
and do anything
i haven't heard anything that she's
trying to do on the ground here if this
is really truly her home
you know there's a lot of people
suffering here so i don't know i don't
even know why she threw that in there
but she did yeah what do you make of
just the the idea that the people who
are screaming the most about
racism these days the people who are
screaming the most about sexism
homophobia the rest of the buzzwords
that in many cases they're the ones who
are pushing it more than anyone else
absolutely i mean we see that a lot with
the whole defund the police narrative
right we live in a city where most of
the crime is perpetrated against black
people
gallup did a poll 81 of black americans
do
not want to defund the police the only
people talking about it
are people that live in gated
communities or they're running around
with security themselves
you know there's not there's not the
people living in these dangerous
community
that are saying defund the police and it
doesn't make any sense if you want
police to be better trained
you want police reform you need more
funding
so it makes absolutely no sense at all
and nobody on the ground is saying that
but yeah that's what we see
you see the people that are living the
elite life uh basically saying this is
what people
living in low-income neighborhoods want
and that's just not true they never take
the cameras
into these neighborhoods and talk to
people on the ground they just act as if
they know what they want
yeah you probably saw you know nancy
pelosi's been kind of
pushing along the riots or not saying
anything about them and then like what
two days ago
someone literally pooped on her driveway
and then suddenly she spoke out
against the riots so it kind of came
home for her okay i know your your phone
is melting and
doing i appreciate you taking the time
where can people go if they want to find
out more about you
and and give one pitch to the people
that don't know you that are just
finding out about you
yes you can definitely go to
kimkayforcongress.com
you can find me on twitter at
kimkbaltimore and i'm honestly
a non-politician just trying to run to
fix the problems that we have
my first and foremost thing is to bring
more career opportunities
to the baltimore area and just back to
america in general
right we see a lot of the cities across
the country right now that are hurting
are cities that once relied on
manufacturing we need to bring those
jobs back home so that's my big thing
kim i thank you for doing this you did a
beautiful thing today the the machine
was coming for you and you punched
back and that's why you're going to get
all the accolades you enjoy it
you deserve it and and have a good
weekend thank you you too
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell